hello and welcome to this video playing
lighting how much lighting how much I
wonder how long it takes until I get the
points back from the cheetah game before
they sometimes are really really fast
with these things
just playing on theoretical opening here
but it cannot be bad you know it's a
very healthy setup
it's not going to be anything special at
headsets also clear
but maybe you can okay wants to go is
quite obvious in his intentions he wants
to play c5 Oh
say anyway to
you
to deal with that probably I need to
look on the open forum
you know it's it's a bit too bit
simplistic here
what's doing with
you
you
you know c5 is going to be okay public
[Music]
that that should be used for movie
blaka can go up g8 or something just
also make it useful move and then go
from there
you
yeah we'll go walk ft8 makes sense
but of course just taking when you form
must be fine if black and c5 and any
resulting position cannot only be
at best
very difficult to be slightly better
there it's probably just equal
lekha spending a bit of time which is
surprising
see how is awesome connection issue I
don't know
you
look like it
makes little sense to spend a lot of
time in discern disposition
hmm there's probably some connection
okay
to have some intermediate move that
makes any sense
probably not
no again it's just it's just equal maybe
I can do this and then claim that I'm a
bit bit quicker on the D file
which is not wrong but it's or should
not net anything special
there are some ways of a new black
screw it up like the 896
now if I do night 27 is Sarah
anything that
I have
probably not Queen e2 is more
but so there is roopd aid and that don't
have anything 97 there's also going to
be route d8
see five
you know it is equal which if they
everything else also equal
maybe he takes and on one d7 that that
would be something but Brooke gh is just
it's just nothing
[Music]
Oh
so there is no root da
each
can play
Fix b6 first and then trying to combine
and play against the pawn I should
probably do this
and
now ask him about the v6 horn now if I
go rook b7 I am attacking b6 and I'm
preparing Luke to d7
it's not um yeah
now 47 there is queen you want check and
f2 is hanging that is true
and it's a good move
now that I should have that I should
have taken into account
how silly
you
and I don't have I don't have anything
now funny funny I absolutely did major
misjudge this
absolutely I need to get rid of the
Queen
now there is see I trade this at least
hmm
great just great
I'm totally
totally miss playing this stuff
you
[Music]
well that's it's very annoying
really that I did not
at least extract something smallish from
this game I mean I definitely had a
rather large advantage
it's super super annoying really you are
on the 7th and just I think that was
just a winning position honestly then I
was played it like that
this I should draw but you still have to
prove it
I'm very difficult for him like to to
try something away but I know that he is
not doing or trying anything
unfortunately this is just absolutely
impossible to do to do anything with
white I just have to have to sit and
wait
it's really not much the same you just
need to sit stay put and see what black
is doing
you know I'm getting the partner
unfortunately I mean there is just
nothing you can do here even if you can
if you say okay is probably not playing
it very well you could have no winning
idea even
qinger form would be simple
this is also rather rather simple
you
I cannot go afford you to the pin but
this is possible of course go here
like a he would have he could have gone
to to fo actually so just to draw
really
[Music]
okay
yes we're going to make a draw him yeah
kind of I don't like that I miss playing
it so much after
here yeah this is super annoying because
this position was really good for white
and I just totally miss played it
like a four looks normal really these g6
heart but okay a freaking resume
somewhere here yeah I should play c4 and
the engine is perfectly perfectly right
to simply stop any b5 stuff
yeah that is better and now
yeah rupee seven is just is just totally
stupid
just totally stupid this move and I just
didn't look at what black could possibly
I answer I mean after this I have no
other moves than returning which makes
rupee seven completely ridiculous and
here you don't have anything anymore I
just just wear too many too many
mistakes and now I should avoid I didn't
just didn't see b5 which is kind of
embarrassing okay
but after Luke d7 I saw would be better
yeah because is a pin it's a pin on
weird
I was really badly tried by me yeah
how do you draw on this this yak windy
voice is actually not not really great
or as well here I should take with the
palm but there I'm just like Quinta
voice it's not good it's very not good
I'm essentially blundering a calm yeah
it here it was a bit strange that he
played Roxy too
definitely would be five gives better
winning chances yeah this this should be
a draw I don't know if I should look at
all those moves
it's basically shuffling and here you
basically blonde at the edge corner way
with the way you play but obviously you
can never never do anything I think I
made one mistake where plate where plate
badly
this care for I thought I should
probably hold it after Luke f8 but it's
a yeah you still have to do this like
check and then go away but it's
important you know this is hang yeah now
it's really just a draw
hmm no I'm not happy with this okay guys
thanks for watching